yeah it's clearly not a threat to
civilization and therefore these guys on
the board uh the folks on the board jump
the fence they did something rash
they're completely inexperienced based
on what I've seen or probably have never
been on the board of a trillion dollar
company or a hundred billion dollar
company with the exception of Adam
D'Angelo obviously cor is a very
important site and he's a pretty
experienced CTO Facebook before that CTO
Facebook I mean's he's he's legit but
this is a dysfunctional board built on a
dysfunctional corporate structure and if
they did have a split with Sam there are
10 different ways you could have handled
this that would have been better the
easiest one would be to say Sam it's
pretty obvious that you want to be doing
these other things we as a board have
decided we want to have a full-time CEO
who doesn't have conflicts therefore
we'd like you to consider you know maybe
moving into another position and
segueing you know over the next year and
what would be a good way for us to
approach this collaboratively to you
know make it great for you and and
obviously not have any reputation damage
we certainly don't want to damage open
AI or the foundation so how can we
collaborate on this instead they shived
him in the middle of the night on Google
meat I mean the ultimate of insults so s
how would you zoom is that what you're
yeah I mean have you used Google me I
mean that's janky well and M Microsoft
put 1010 billion in the company they
couldn't even be forced to use teams or
how about in person how about we do this
you know at a at a dinner at an offsite
or you know we have a we have a
thoughtful one-on-one we do a walk can
talk if you're going to ask someone Sam
alman's profile who put his life into
this and his reputation to move out of
that top spot how would you handle that
sax if you did have this philosophical
Arrangement what would be the proper
protocol here well look we don't even
know that they did I mean we've it's
we're speculating about something where
they haven't even provided an
explanation I mean again based on Ilia
retracting it seems like there is no
explanation but look I I think that if
if one were to look for a root call
of this whole thing that goes beyond you
know just the immediate events of the
last few days I would say it has to be
the the nonprofit structure the original
nonprofit structure and this funky you
know this funky corporate structure that
have been set up with this weird board
that consists of a bunch of people who
don't really have skin in the game like
no VCS as far as I can tell and people
with you know fancy titles and effective
altruism or whatever basically you know
people who main credentials seem to be
liberal arts majors and stuff like that
I mean for for one thing I guess when
this first happened I was really
surprised that Sam could even be fired
because I just kind of assumed that he
had control over the board I mean as the
principal founder CEO I just figured he
had control so I was very surprised that
something like this could even happen um
you know on our pod I speculated that he
must have ownership in this it just
can't be the case that he has zero own
ownership and I guess I was wrong about
that I mean I guess I guess he really
doesn't have equity and he really didn't
have control I mean I'm I guess that's
probably the most surprising thing to me
about the whole thing and I guess that
Springs from the fact that it was set up
in this funky nonprofit way and I just
think it just all goes back to the point
that um you you can't do better than a
Delaware SE Corp you know whenever I see
Founders trying to innovate on structure
legal structure I know can be a disaster
like that's not where Founders should be
innovating they should Founders should
be innovating on product and Technology
not in coming up with you know new
fangled corporate structures and or
charts and governance and all this kind
of stuff and I think there was a
skepticism before chat GPT came out on
November 30th last year I think there
was kind of a general skepticism about
what open AI was doing not because you
know um the people involved weren't seen
as serious but just it was just seem as
bizarre like the idea that a nonprofit
Foundation could somehow be on The
Cutting Edge of technology and lead to
some sort of you know uh technological
Revolution I think most people would
have thought that was the really
fanciful idea I mean nonprofits have
their place in the world but it's just
not generally pushing the boundaries of
of Discovery and Innovation right it's
more about Distributing products that
already exist to needy people um so in
any event I mean the structure was
always really weird and um it appears
that the weirdness never fully went away
I mean they tried to paper over it they
tried to create these complicated
crisscrossing structures that allowed
Microsoft and others to invest but they
never fully solved the problem um that
the alignment that was set up in the
beginning just wasn't very good um and I
think one of the alignment problems is
that Sam didn't have a proper comp
package and I think the board wasn't set
up as a proper board I mean you know for
all the that VC get like you know
VC's and I think you made this point
Jason VC's wouldn't fire a Founder where
everything is going up and to the right
like that's suicidal quite the opposite
what did they do with what did they do
with Elon when it was up and to the
right and he was fully vested they
created a comp package to keep him there
right you're talking about Tesla yeah
I'm talking about Tesla Tesla created a
comp package where the more the better
Tesla did in terms of his public
valuation the more stock he got so he
had these very far out of the money
stock options I think Tesla was worth I
don't know tens of billions at that
point and his comp package went all the
way up to 600 billion meaning that if
the company would ever be valued at 600
billion he would invest additional uh
additional owner so they gave him these
far out of the money stock options so
the better the company did the more
ownership he got um yeah I mean everyone
had skin in The game everyone was
aligned I mean this is the beauty of the
um I I think of of the way that the star
ecosystem works from just a a legal and
structural point of view is it's I I
don't think that Silicon Valley would
work without the innovation of the joint
stock company right you create a company
and you have widespread ownership by
Founders VCS and employees and
everybody's Aline everyone has skin in
the game and then you know within that
framework the founders run the company
and typically have very broad latitude
to do what they want and everyone's
comfortable with that because everyone's
aligned and when everything is up and to
the right and working no one messes with
that it's only when things descend some
sort of Crisis or you know there's some
sort of criminal issue or something
really really horrible do you ever like
typically get a big intervention but
otherwise when things are working you
just leave them alone because again
everybody's ly for that big outcome this
is the key point you know the structure
here sunny in Silicon Valley has been
perfected over decades and it's been
battle tested right and the Delaware SE
laws are the you know the manifestation
and the codification of that this
Franken structure Franken structure they
came up with you know which they I think
they modeled off of Mozilla and the
Milla Foundation because they started
printing hundreds of millions of dollars
in Google AdSense Revenue this is the
original sin then you put a bunch of you
know non uh stock price incented
individuals on the board and you get
this weird outcome you can say all the
terrible things you want in the world
about capitalism and VCS but the focus
let me just add something to that okay
there was a widespread belief or a
belief that a lot of people are indulged
in and maybe even Sam and this could
have been his downfall that somehow open
AI would be a more trustworthy company
if it did not intend to make a
profit this was sort of the premise
behind all this Foundation nonsense
is that if open AI does not intend to
turn a profit we can all trust it
more and you heard repeated over and
over in many different ways and I think
even Sam may have bought into this and I
think ultimately that was the end doing
here this is a we if we level up the
conversation Sachs I if you think about
operating systems for building things in
the world for changing Humanity say what
you want about capitalism but it aligns
perfectly with hard driving people and
capital allocators it aligns perfectly
and it is a more trustworthy situation
because you can trust that everybody's
working towards increasing the share
price and the share price obviously
represents something in the world it
represents progress so again you can
hate capitalism it's imperfect but it's
the best system for building companies
and changing Humanity in the best way
and I think that's ultimately what we'll
see here is this is going to be um what
do you call it when you have like an
ultimate decision there's a word for
this but it would be the ultimate
decision on capitalism versus nonprofits
just to butress your point there let me
quote Adam
Smith uh what Adam Smith wrote this is
in the 1700s is that it is not from the
benevolence of the butcher the Brewer or
the baker that we expect our dinner but
from their regard to their own interest
in other words we can trust people in
capitalism not because um they're going
to do some altruistic for us but because
they're going to pursue their own
self-interest and in so doing they're
going to produce something that we all
want I mean that was basically what Adam
Smith said right if you don't what
happens it's that profit interest that
allows us to understand their
motivations and to align their
incentives with something that's good
for all of us now as soon as you take
away that profit incentive say for
example by putting a bunch of effective
alist on your
board um you know now you don't really
know what what it is that they're
optimizing for they claim they're
optimizing for some principle or other
but it may just be you know some crazy
idea in their head that we shouldn't
trust or it might be some bureaucratic
incentive these people for social credit
let's call it what it is they're doing
it credit or they they want social
credit some resume packing item or some
who knows who knows it's some sort of
but but you're never going to take human
um incentives motivations out of
something you're just going to replace
the profit motive with some other kind
of motive that might be even more
nefarious and you're wondering like how
did this happen I think one of the
reasons why it's so
inexplicable is because we don't know
the motivations of these board members
and you pointed out before Sam did not
have a package this is if you were on a
board and your CEO who was doing this
deal making was so important and
critical and they didn't own 10 20% of
the company and their future incentives
were not aligned and you didn't have him
locked up for the next five years that
would be job one of the board is get Sam
a package and lock him down and maybe
the reason he was doing these side deals
was because he wasn't compensated open a
totally I think I think that's an
excellent point is look we don't know
what side deals he was doing but he was
running around making a lot of deals I
guess there's been a couple that been
reported but if you're worried about
that if that was the worry reup the guy
massively you know give him a huge um
stock package you know give him the Elon
package they did a test yes and you know
so that he's singularly focused on
making open AI successful but again this
goes back to the the motivations of this
foundation and this funky setup they had
it's not clear what it is they were
optimizing for I mean I guess some
vision of societal good but who judges
that you know and so at the end of the
day it just becomes a highly political
thing where you got a room full of
people and you know they they're
optimizing for some sort of
you know bizarre political Dynamic are
you building the next great AI product
well if so you know how expensive apis
can be for their model training data
training AI is pricey that's a fact we
all know it so you have to try the brave
search API yes I am talking about Brave
the Privacy browser that I am obsessed
with Brave's browser has 65 million
users think about how much data that
drives for brave search which is the
only global scale independent search
index outside of big and that index is
available to anyone with the brave
search API the brave search API can
power your chat Bots and train your
models inform answers to real-time
queries and it will serve images web
results and even Rich Text Snippets the
brave search API features an easy
intuitive data structure and its data is
populated by real human interaction not
web crawlers all for a fraction of the
cost of the major players it's free for
up to 2,000 queries per month with paid
plans for as little as a $3 CPM that's
cost per thousand so if you're building
an nextg app or chatbot you got to try
the brave search API get started today
brave.com Jason oh Jason's Brave I like
it brave.com Jason and get the browser
while you at it it is awesome it's also
got a VPN built in that's pretty
cool